las jugadoras del Campeonato de Francia
la conocen bien y las que no la
conocerán en el mundial a sus 38 años
Stephanie pack es la primera mujer
francesa en arbitrar un partido de la
Copa del Mundo masculina hace apenas
tres años Stephanie fue la primera mujer
en arbitrar la liga a francesa y después
en la final de la Copa del Mundo
femenina en su país luego arbitró la
Liga de Campeones en 2020 y la final de
la Copa de Francia la temporada pasada
hoy es una de las tres mujeres elegidas
para el torneo de Qatar
me sentí muy emocionada porque el
mundial es el evento más importante del
mundo del deporte no solo del fútbol es
ha sido importante
y sí que estoy muy orgullosa de
representar a Francia en el mundial así
como al arbitraje francés
Stephanie empezó a arbitrar a los 13
años en su ciudad natal
donde también jugaba el fútbol su
antigua compañera de recuerda Cómo era
jugar con Estefany
era relativamente introvertida en la
vida cotidiana no hablaba mucho de sí
misma ni de sus sentimientos pero en el
campo era una persona que empujaba a los
demás y les daba consejos y solía decir
siempre la gente en el campo que no se
rindiera solía decir vamos chicas
llegamos hasta el final
Stephanie será la primera mujer en
dirigir un partido de la copa mundial
cuando Alemania se enfrente a Costa Rica
en el partido del grupo e del jueves
este hito en su carrera marca también un
hito para las mujeres en el deporte y
demuestra que hay y cada vez Habrá más
lugar para ellas en el